the story of Pharma bro Martin shkreli
is getting stranger and stranger this is
the guy who initially came to prominence
when touring pharmaceuticals got a
license for the medication daraprim and
it raised the price from $13.50 per pill
to seven hundred and fifty dollars per
pill after that
shkreli ended up getting himself
arrested and charged with securities
fraud totally unrelated to the daraprim
fiasco and it had to do with him
allegedly having used company funds as a
sort of personal slush fund at some
prior point and now martin shkreli has
been sent to jail but again it has
nothing to do with either the daraprim
fiasco nor directly with the securities
fraud incident it's because he offered
on face book a $5,000 reward for a
strand of Hillary Clinton's hair
shkreli was only free because he had
posted five million dollars bail
awaiting sentencing for his security
fraud case and he made to post to
facebook offering cash to anybody who
would grab a hair from Hillary Clinton's
head during her book tour
he later edited the post to say this was
meant to be satirical and eventually
took it down altogether but prosecutors
went to a judge in Brooklyn New York and
they said no there's a risk that one of
this guy's followers is going to take it
seriously and actually try to assault
Hillary Clinton by pulling out one of
her hairs and a Brooklyn judge named Keo
Matsumoto said oh no no no I agree the
Facebook post could be seen as a real
threat it's sort of a solicitation to
assault someone in exchange for money
and that's not protected by the First
Amendment so shkreli now is in jail he
might be there until January 16th which
is when his sentencing will happen and
as I read through the story I thought oh
hold on a second
posting on Facebook that someone should
get a hair from Hillary that's a
solicitation worthy of being thrown in
jail but when Trump suggests someone
hack Hillary's emails including maybe
Russia that's not a concern to anybody
in law enforcement how do these two
things square up at all or when Trump
invites his fans to
eat up some protester right and that's
how they used to do it right we used to
just brought them up that's apparently
completely fine the good old days
turns out offering people offering to
pay people to steal hair from a former
Secretary of State and Senator when
you're out on bail is not a good idea
and there's some irony here because
shkreli once tweeted something about
Hillary's gonna end up going to jail now
he's in jail after what a judge
considered an inducement to violence
against Hillary Clinton
I see Trump and shkreli is pretty
similar actually they both believe
they're above the law they seem to have
significant delusions of grandeur
there's this really funny story about
Martin shkreli a girl once wrote an
article about how she was on I believe
it was tinder one of the other mobile
dating apps and she ended up matching
with Martin shkreli and she thought this
guy is is not someone I like or I'm on
board with ideologically but what the
heck this will be a story I'll go on a
date with him and she talks about how
the entire thing was kind of weird and
shkreli is just really socially awkward
but that at a certain point there was
like a $200 tea on the menu so most he
is like $2 $3 $4 there was some super
rare tea on the menu and she said that
at the end of the date shkreli ordered
it and I don't remember the details of
the story but the entire thing just
seems totally surreal and like the guy
is exactly what we imagined him to be I
saw an interview with him and a vice
reporter and he started playing chess
with the Vice reporter and the vice
reporter made it clear that she doesn't
really know how to play chess that's
just not her thing yeah any of course he
does this condescending thing about
saying like oh you commonly employ the
Sicilian defense do you like she doesn't
play chess it's a that's a it's a vice
piece about shkreli that has two or
three million views it's about a year
old you can find that if you go on
YouTube and just type in Martin shkreli
vice chess hey here's a good candidate
for Trump - pardon right in addition to
Joe Arpaio shkreli a great American
absolutely the best totally sandbagged
by liberal activist judges I mean the
judges in Brooklyn after all it's all
hipsters there this is one of the
strangest ways to break your bail - I
mean I've never heard of anything like
this but maybe he just thought that in
his audience was one of Hillary
Clinton's hairdressers and that they
would be a viable candidate to send him
one of
yeah and that of course no crime would
be committed it wouldn't be assault that
would all be absolutely fine the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad